encanto's golden child isabella was
originally very different she had a
secret boyfriend and got married was a
book lover like belle and could grow
magical potato people yipikai movie
lovers i'm jan and in this video i'm
revealing isabella's deleted scenes and
rejected storylines that you never got
to see some spoilers ahead so take care
one of the funniest moments in the movie
is when the magic goes wrong at
isabella's proposal dinner as the
family's powers misfire issa's true
feelings about picture perfect mariano
sprout up subconsciously revealing that
she doesn't want to marry him however in
an earlier version of the story isabella
had a different boyfriend that she chose
for herself who she'd meet up with in
secret in the woods in an official
deleted scene mirabelle spots her sister
getting dragged into the forest by a
mysterious hooded character and chases
after her thinking she's in danger
seeing what looks like an animal
approach isabella mirabelle attacks the
mystery creature until she discovers
that it's actually boobo marquez are you
all right i am fine miami
[Music]
just go home you saw nothing i wish i
saw nothing what i did see was like two
baby birds feeding each other bulbourt
was from the city so an outsider to the
encanto and combined with his quirky
personality the intention was for him to
have a comical fish out of water vibe
i'm wearing this jaguar print coat wild
animals see it and they're like is that
a jaguar and i'm all yes and they're
like i will not mess with him
most predators hunt by smell which is
why i covered it in the urine of several
animals the deleted scene continued with
isabella revealing that she planned to
leave the encanto with bubo presumably
to go to the city you're trying to leave
the place where every person worships
the ground you walk on to go
out there
what is this dark magic bubo is the only
person who has ever really seen me and
this moment before the barrier is
restored is our only chance to be free
so in this version of isabella's story
it appears that something had happened
to open the barrier that kept the
encanto separated from the outside world
and perhaps this was an early sign that
the family's magic was weakening
although there's some humor in this
scene such as mirabelle's reaction to
the super awkward kissing i can see why
it was cut as many of the audience might
have found it as uncomfortable to watch
as mirabelle did and many fans reacted
in horror when they saw this deleted
scene also having bullbot as isabella's
love interest would have shifted the
focus of her arc away from discovering
what she wanted for herself in her life
plus it's kind of cliche in terms of its
quirky guy and pretty girl trope that
we've seen many times before in the end
this romantic plot for isabella was
replaced with issa rejecting the suit
that abuela had lined up for her and
making choices for herself that didn't
depend on a love interest i never wanted
to marry him i was doing it for the
family an alternate version of the bubo
scene can also be found in this unused
concept art of a secret garden created
by isabella that mirabelle wanders into
it looks like it could have been an
amusing moment and it reminds me a lot
of the lilies scene in disney's the
princess and the frog
and in another version of isabella's
secret garden mirabelle descended into a
spiky dark thicket of trees with creepy
faces embedded in the wood and bruno who
looked very different in earlier stories
followed mirabelle into the spooky area
which was deliberately designed like
that by isabella to scare people away so
they wouldn't find out about her secret
boyfriend
warbor haters will also be shocked to
discover that isabella was originally
going to marry him in one of encanto's
epilogues clearly from the celebrations
the family had accepted bubo by this
point and given the way the bride and
groom kiss here it looks like issa and
bubo's heavy makeout sessions were going
to be a running joke in this version of
the story a fun bonus in this original
ending is how it looks like it was
dolores who caught the bridal bouquet
and ended up with mariano as she wanted
to in the final movie as well let's get
miriam slow down in an alternate take on
the story isabella also loved to read
and she created giant hydrangeas in her
room that she and booboo would lie on
giving them a feeling of floating on a
cloud in this story the clouds
represented isabella's desire to be free
and true to herself while at the same
time she was still trapped in her room
this whole shot is stunning from the
detail of the sun on the floor to the
walls of glass which made the room
resemble a vars for putting flowers on
display just as abuela put issa on
display and you can see mirabelle
peeking into the room where presumably
she would have caught issa with bubba
and i love this little test animation of
isabella creating a flower seat and
plant light bulb to read her book i
wonder if they decided against her being
a book lover though as that on top of
her general disney princess vibe might
have made her feel a little too
reminiscent of belle from beauty and the
beast
there's a small but funny deleted moment
from just before mirabelle hugs it out
with her sister where isabella makes fun
of mirabelle by doing an impression of
her with glasses made out of her vines
this would have ended up causing a
full-on fight between the two sisters i
can see why the physical fight was cut
though as it's a little tropey and i
think the scene we got of isabella's
repressed emotions coming through as
flowers sprouting up in mirabelle's face
was funnier and more interesting as her
anger at having to be constantly perfect
finally bubbles up to the surface
an amazing concept for isabella which
sadly didn't make it into the movie was
her ability to create animated plant
creatures such as these potato
characters these living potatoes dressed
in traditional outfits would have
populated the house and even tended
their own crops leave a thumbs up if you
love these little guys and there was an
awesome deleted scene where they helped
mirabelle learn about the history of a
big battle by re-enacting it together
with an army of magical wallpaper
soldiers created by casita by the way
casita's magical wallpaper is another
deleted concept which i'll be discussing
more in my next video so make sure
you're subscribed and click the
notification bell to get that video
in another cut epilogue scene we can see
that isabella's door design had both
books and crossed swords on it and there
would have been a fun moment where she
emerged and it was revealed that she'd
been fencing with bulbar inside her room
where they'd been role-playing something
from a book that they'd read earlier and
at one point in the story isabella was
going to have a punk rock look i expect
this would have come at the moment when
she decided being a senorita perfecta
wasn't what she really wanted so
transformed her look from soft pastel
shades to much bolder colors ending up
with a splatter paint design the punk
rock version of her would have hinted at
an even edgier sense about her newfound
self but perhaps it would have been a
bit too cliche for her to go from a
classic disney princess vibe to a
full-on rebel child
and had bubo made it into the final cut
he would have also been in the final
frame where one of bruno's rats takes a
picture of the family and we get the
running joke again of issa and bubo
smooching together in fact there were
even more alternate endings that were
cut from encounter including a hilarious
post-credits scene with a capybara plus
a surprise ending for camilo tap here to
learn all about those and there's also a
link in the video description and if
you'd like to see more gorgeous concept
art from encanto consider getting a copy
of the art of encanto book there's a
link in the description on how you can
get it with free worldwide shipping so
are you a booboo lover or hater and do
you wish any of these isabella deleted
scenes have been in the movie let me
know in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video do leave a thumbs up
i really appreciate it next tap left for
even more encounter deleted scenes
including a giant camilo transforming
into bruno that will be my next video
thanks for enjoying this movie with me
and hope you have a marvellous movie
loving week yippie kai movie lovers